foreign
foreign
before we begin people are probably
wondering where is the Army
unfortunately you see brother Rami on
the on the thumbnail that I made but he
couldn't make it he has some uh last
minute circumstances coming up
so inshallah without further Ado let's
get into it on her bro what's on your
mind
man first I want to hear a background
story on you brother and assalamu
alaikum how are you
when you read the clear Quran there's
like a little bit of a of a forward or
like pretext and then uh I remember a
little bit of the story into what what
made you want to translate it right I
think you were in a taxi or an Uber or
something like that but for anyone
that's here they don't they don't know
the story they don't know the details
why don't you begin with that insha
Allah
so the story happened in Toronto back in
2013. so I was visiting Imam at a local
Masjid
and I didn't have a car back then
because it was just one month so I used
to take you know taxis every day back
and forth
and if you have been to Toronto many of
the cab drivers are Muslim alhamdulillah
but that particular day it so happened
that the cab driver was not Muslim
so uh I was sitting in the back and uh
all of a sudden he said you know what
uh Muslims are good people but Islam
sucks and I say whoa whoa why why do you
say that and he said because
your book the Quran calls me an animal
and I said bro um Quran I know the Quran
by heart it doesn't say that anywhere
and he cited 855. and the verse says
that the words of old I'm going to
explain this word in a minute
are the disbelievers
and I said bro but the word does not
mean animals because Allah explains this
word in another verse in the Quran
because the Quran explains each other
you know the verses explain each other
I said verse chapter 24 verse 45 Allah
says Allah explains the word he says
Allah created uh every daba from water
some Slither on their bellies some walk
onto feet some walk on four feet and so
on and so forth so it's a very general
term and if you read the context the
historical background of the verse it
says in the same verse that uh namely
those pagans that they make peace
agreements with you and they violate
them every single time so it's talking
about the people of Makkah it's not
talking about the people of New York or
the people of Toronto and he said this
is what his translation says
so that night I checked there is a
website called uh islamawakened.com so
for every Ayah every verse of the Quran
they give you back then it used to be
about 40 45 translations now I believe
the number went up to about 70 75 and
that night back in 2013 I checked the
website and I found out that many of
them say either animal or beast
and I said you know what that's it I'm
going to work on my own translation so I
studied Islamic Studies in English and
translation so that was my field and I
used to give out dawa translations like
the old one verily uh vow beneficent all
those difficult words and I know that
the translations had had some issues but
I didn't know it was that bad
so alhamdulillah that night I decided I
I made the intention to translate the
Quran to make to make the Quran more
accessible and to translate it in a way
that people can understand and relate to
alhamdulillah
so how many languages has it been
translated to so like thus far
well we have we have done several
editions of the clear Quran so there's
the original one then we did one with
the Arabic English
uh then we did the heaves Edition
we did the parallel Edition with it one
with osmanuscript and one with the
Indian Pakistani script and now we are
in the phase of printing uh the tadapur
Quran the journal study Quran so half of
the page you see the text on the other
half we left it blank so you can add
your own or the gems that you come
across
the clearground for kids this is this is
something else masha'allah
it has been edited by kids between the
ages of seven to twelve uh also we a
couple of years ago we released the
clearchron dictionary
uh because the Quran has only 2 000 Ruth
words in Arabic and this is a very small
number
so if you master those 2000 words in
about six months then you understand the
whole Quran in Arabic you don't need the
translation anymore
so I did this one specifically for my
nana Arab uh Muslim brothers and sisters
alhamdulillah
the less one where can we find that one
would you find it on Amazon like the
other ones as well uh you can but you
can go to our website the clearquran.org
it has all the Editions
I'll put all the links in the
description
go ahead go ahead
yeah we also have apps for the
dictionary and also for the uh for the
uh for the Quran translation
so question
by any chance
I don't know if this is under you or
someone else just kind of like took a
fancy to the name the clear Quran but um
there's one that I saw it was like the
clear Quran but in Spanish
do you have someone that like translated
it in Spanish so basically uh because
the clear Quran alhamdulillah has been
made I accessible and and easy with the
pseudo introductions and the titles and
the footnotes so uh Imam Isa Garcia the
Spanish translator of the Quran his
translation is very popular in Spanish
and he happened to be publishing with my
publisher and for clan foundation in
Chicago
so we spoke to him and we made a deal
that he's going to model his translation
after the clear Quran so he took the
introductions of the clip on the heroes
paragraph titles and the footnotes and
he modeled his translation after mine
and now they call it the clear Quran in
Spanish yeah yeah I think I think about
that one for my grandpa yes
alhamdulillah excellent yeah
the kids speak is being translated into
10 different languages
uh Japanese uh Urdu Bangla
Dutch Turkish German Spanish French
many translations because to the best of
my knowledge there is nothing like this
in in the market they usually have all
translations black and white no stories
but this one because it it has been
edited by kids and when you read it you
get this you get the sense that it was
written by another kid so I feel there's
a lot of demand for this translation
because it really takes the clear the
translation for kids to the next level
to make it more accessible to them
hmm I love about a gun I mean
you said that one specifically the kids
version is going to be translating all
these different languages what about the
clear Quran itself is that gonna see
like a French Edition at some point and
all these other languages
maybe in a few in the future but there
are some I've said
requirements the translation to be done
number one the translation of the Quran
itself has to be done from the Arabic
directly
I don't want it to be gone from the
English
the kids edition what makes it different
so basically the translators let's say
Turkish
so the Turkish team that translates the
clear Quran they basically translate the
text of the Quran alhamdulillah
from Arabic
then you have my own FC and my own
explanation stories these are my own
words they can translate them but the
text of the Quran itself has to be done
directly from the Arabic and this is why
inshallah if we do the translation in
the future it has to be done by a team
that knows the target language let's say
German Spanish and the original language
the Arabic language and they can use the
clickron as a reference
uh so let's say if there's a verse that
have different meanings I chose one
based on scholarly discussions they are
going to take my preference they're
going to use my footnotes my titles my
Surah introductions explanations
everything but the text itself the Quran
the Arabi it has to be translated
directly from the Arab
[Music]
so how long did it take you
in total to actually do everything yeah
I was gonna ask this too like total like
how long did it take you to translate
I started back in 2013 so it's almost 10
years since I started
let's jump right into the questions do
you have anything or should I go
I I just wanted to say something before
we get the questions that yeah inshallah
we have to acknowledge that no
translation is perfect not the clear
Quran
nobody else right uh because the the
translation of the Quran basically is an
imperfect human effort to translate the
perfect word of Allah
so we have to keep refining the work
improving it tweaking it uh so I think
that is perfect is the Arabi text the
Arabic text of the Quran my translation
is a humble human effort uh there are
some decent good translations out there
by the Giants of translation like
Muhammad Abdul halim from Oxford
and I think the click on is also a
decent translation uh
but there are some other translations
really that were done by people who are
not qualified to translate in the first
place
like let's say there's uh this uh an
electronics engineer or by this
accountant like if you read the
introduction to their work they say in
their own introduction we're not
qualified we have no training whatsoever
and my answer is like dude if you're not
qualified to do it why did you do it in
the first place and they end up just
copying use of Ali pixel
International all these all the
translations they start copying them
because
they will not qualify I know they were
motivated by their love for Islam they
wanted to do something they wanted to
leave a legacy but they really did a
great disservice how do I know because
some of those translations when you go
out to do Street dawa some missionaries
will come to you with some of those
older translations oh there's a mistake
here there's a contradiction there and
they say uh the Quran says that it has
no contradictions but there is one here
one here one there and I tell them dude
this is not the Quran this somebody's
understanding of the Quran if you want
to criticize if you want to critique you
have to go to the Arabic text but this
is not the Quran right
so just like you cannot trust any doctor
with your body you have to go to a
professional doctor not some guy who's
sitting down the road with a with a sign
that handwritten sign that says I'm a
doctor no it has to be someone who's
qualified
right so if we don't trust our body to
someone who is not qualified how can we
trust on Iman to people who are not
qualified to translate in the first
place yeah so I think this is something
and it's really interesting because I
have been in the uh
in the Interfaith field for so many
years Muslims are the only community
that will accept translations of the
their own book their own scripture uh by
people who are not qualified
you go to the Jewish Community give them
a translation of the Old Testament by
someone who's not trained
they were not accepted Christians Buddha
nobody will accept a translation of
their own holy book that has been done
by someone who's not qualified
you know so I think this is something
that we need to think about deeply just
take your translations from reliable
sources
right
yeah you know right
no no it's a good man though because
look like when I first came into Islam
because I'm a river by the way but when
I first came to the slam I had read the
old English and um even though it's it's
more difficult to comprehend it's still
got the message through right and that's
where you'll notice is like if someone's
sincere if someone's pure in their heart
and Allah's guiding them they're gonna
receive the message regardless if it's
difficult to interpret or not now
I used to hear that like oh the Arabic
the Arabic is like where the real words
are where the real translation is and
I'm like yeah okay I get that because in
like Spanish you know like Spanish is
different than English but it's like
when I I have this brother who's
teaching me Arabic may I love listen and
like the more he teaches me the more I
learn and I'm reciting he's like kind of
just breaking things down for me and we
listen to like tough series I'm just
like
all right Savannah it actually is like
the Arabic language especially back then
like the one that's compromised of the
the Quran it's such a rich language
where you have one word that can it can
be it can mean so many different things
they're true so it's like when you say
this I can comprehend that now and I'll
I don't want you to think that um
the clear Quran isn't like
a top top book in that Series in terms
of the interpretation because I'm gonna
tell you one thing
I've read many qurans and the clerical
and to this day has been the one that's
been
for like a bit of words the clear Quran
in English at least
and before someone asks the question
I'll have to give you the answer why the
clear Quran why did we choose this name
because some people say are you saying
that other translations are not clear
and I said this is not the point because
when I was looking for a a name for the
book
uh who is better than Allah to give a
title for his book
so the Quran has titles for the Quran so
you have a Quran in this is mentioned in
the Quran the great Quran
the Glorious Quran
then we have Al-Quran the clear Quran so
Allah refers to the Quran as clear twice
in chapter 15 at the beginning in
chapter 36 at the end so we took this
out we took this from the Quran so the
Quran is clear and this is the
translation of the clear revelation
so this is the reasoning and this goes
like for other translations like the
noble Quran are you telling me that the
other translations are not Noble
the Glorious Quran are the other ones
not glorious no this is just the title
of the book which is different from the
translation itself
so I just wanted to clarify this you
know muscle allow good clarification
alhamdulillah
oh no bro you got any questions or
should we go in bro I I literally have
taken all the spotlight with
with uh
okay let's go and then so I I have a
mentally compiled like a list of
questions for you these are things that
I hear from everyone and I'm seeing
commonalities between them
um they're gonna be from people that are
non-muslims usually right because these
are the people that are like hey I went
on YouTube and I saw a video by this guy
you know who's probably like some fake
ex Muslim or an islamophobe you know and
they always use different translations
of the Quran to fit a narrative that
they're trying to propagate you know
what I mean so this is a big problem in
the community we can talk about this
um but again these are non-muslims we
can't really control their actions all
we could do is refute them they've been
refuted multiple times but they always
come at you with this right and they'll
say that okay
first question why was the Quran in
Arabic if Islam is a universal language
not not a language of Islam it's a
universal religion and the message is
supposed to be transferred to anyone
regardless of which language they speak
why was why was Arabic why Arabic
that's a very good
so you will understand
some of those attacks at the Quran
really they are not new they have been
recycled for so many years
and the first people to actually
highlight those questions were Muslims
themselves you go back to the teachings
of Azam is a great uh interpreter of the
Quran in history and so many others they
will tell you in there to see it what
does the Quran say this our answer is
this so even before the islamophobes
could think of those questions Muslims
actually compiled those questions and
they gave the answers long before the
Islamic folks could come up with those
questions
so
some of them some of the old Scholars
say said okay why Arabic
so one of them I believe it was
zamakshari he said the same could have
been said about any language imagine if
Allah revealed the Quran in Spanish
then the Chinese people or the the
French people say why not French why not
Chinese why not Urdu you know so he said
that Allah had to really to reveal the
Quran in one language because it
couldn't be revealed in all the 214 or
250 languages more or less in the world
for Allah chose the best one
the Arabic language
is so rich
so the Arabic language basically has 6
000 roots six thousand roots and from
those six thousand Roots we derive more
than 12 million 500 000 words
12 million 500 Words million words this
is 25 times the number of words in the
English language
almost 98 times the number of words in
the Russian language
but English 25 times the number of words
in the English language for the Arabic
language is very rich there is a book
someone wrote a book historically
about the names that we have in the
Arabic language for Lion l-i-o-n and the
list was over a thousand words a
thousand words poor lion just one word
all means or names were lion in the
Arabic language
we have about 25 different levels of
friendship about 25 different levels of
sleep
then
it's so rich and subhanallah I'll just
give you one example to illustrate
like when I read the tafsir the
explanation of the Quran in Arabic
sometimes one word in in an Ayah in the
Quran has like five seven ten different
meanings and all of them are acceptable
in the Arabic language the example that
I always like to give
Islam started to smash the idols with
his Yamin okay so the word you mean
could mean with his right hand
right when you have the ax he was using
his right hand
the word you mean in Arabic language
also means and uh it means power
he was smashing the idols with all of
his might and Power
also it could mean he smashed him by
virtue of the oath that he had taken
when he said Wallah he I'm going to
destroy you so this is called the amine
in Arabic and oath
all of these meanings are acceptable in
this Ayah which language can give you
all these different meanings in one word
none only the Arabic language and this
is why the Quran had to be revealed in
the Arabic language
on top of that
the Arabic language is the most
beautiful language in the world when it
comes to writing you can look at the
calligraphy go to Istanbul see the the
massage the way words are written the
Arabic language will always be useful
until
so for example the Quran was revealed
1500 years ago tell this day even people
in my Village in Egypt who didn't go to
school who couldn't read or write if
they listened to the recitation they
would understand at least 90 percent of
what is happening
I went to school you guys went to school
bring me a text from Shakespeare from
400 450 years ago I bet you you will not
understand 98 of what he is talking
about
that's 400 years ago
so so these are just some like a small
flavor of how beautiful the Arabic
language is there is no other language
that will match this beauty and power
some of the scholars say that the
language the original language that Adam
came with to this world some say Allahu
Adam we don't know it was the Arabic
language and they give you a proof from
so many languages that they have so many
words that have been borrowed from the
Arabic language just one example
uh as I said the Quran the clear Quran
dictionary the Quran has only 2 000 root
words
this is one wrote it comes from one root
uh so I listed the words based on
frequency and theme not alphabetically
so basically uh when you study a regular
dictionary of the Quran if you read the
first 20 Pages
all these words appeared only once in
the Quran so when you start to read the
Quran you don't understand anything if
you if Arabic is not your language but
if you study the clear Quran dictionary
the most frequent words are mentioned at
the beginning the least frequent are
mentioned at the end and the words are
grouped based on meaning so fruits are
together prophets are together
um nature words related to Nature are
together the names of Allah together and
so on and so forth time plays and so on
and so forth
so uh the uh the Arabic language as I
said is very rich as I said two thousand
words make up all the words of the Quran
and as I said in the introduction to the
clearchron dictionary you already know a
hundred of those words because they were
taken from the Quran and they are used
in the English language and you don't
even know
so you already know 100 of them let me
give you a few examples
do you know the word merge merge
in Arabic means merge in English
then you have the word
fake in English it comes from the word
if
fake
tall in English
in Arabic
[Music]
damage in English comes from the Arabic
word
is in the Quran to damage
right there are so many ways these are
just a few examples and solid and and
sold and art and Earth
they come from the Arabic language
yeah so there's so many reasons
what are the questions you got
man my mind is blank bro just just
taking all that in subhanallahu okay I
have a question I have a question then
one uh brother Mustafa how long did it
take you to become a Hafiz
well I joined al-azhar in Egypt at the
age of seven
and I completed my health at the age of
12. that was a requirement that al-assad
that you have to memorize the Quran uh
between you know grade one to to that
great
from the age of seven to the age of 12.
so would you say it actually came easy
to you since you know in in Egypt you
guys speak Arabic
well again everyone is different but the
way that we're doing it
you memorize new sections you have to
review them before you memorize them we
used to write them down
and the teacher with the review would
review with you the section that you're
going to memorize to make sure that
you're actually pronouncing the words
correctly because if you if you memorize
it wrong it's very difficult to unlearn
what you have learned in the wrong way
so then we would go the next day and
recite
of the top of our heads uh to the shank
and he would give us a new section and
we have to review the old sections that
we have memorized it's easy to memorize
the Quran but it's extremely difficult
to retain it to keep it in your mind so
you have to keep revising you have to
keep revising
interesting
so
if you don't mind I would like to ask a
few personal questions please and if you
feel like you don't want to answer them
100 respectable even though this is live
we can't cut anything out but I I will
respect if you don't want to answer
anything one thing I wanted
yes the Arabs have the advantage to
memorize the Quran because it's in their
own their own language
but how come that most of the people who
win international competitions of
quranic memorization are not Arab
um
so they come from Nigeria they come from
Indonesia they come from other countries
they don't speak Arabic
so this is the miracle of the Quran
Allah says
we have made it easy
so subhanallah
this upon over
all right well if you don't mind some
personal questions I have for you so
sure uh you said you said you're an Imam
and that you were in Toronto and you
were at the Masjid and doing stuff
how long have you been an Imam for and
is everything that you do like are you
just an Imam like full time
or would you say like you do also some
other stuff because like we've met some
people with their their chefs but at the
same time they might work at um
I don't know maybe like accounting or
maybe something like that yes
so I started my Imam career
in July of this year I had a talk from
the Imam job
really retired and before I return
oh bro we lost oh no it was getting
juicy too I know bro every every episode
bro
foreign
someone writing can you guide me I want
to sincerely learn about Islam best
thing I would recommend is this
the Quran like just read the Quran read
the clear Quran get get a copy of the
clear Quran
um this right here is the translator of
it inshallah still don't know where he
is I think that oh and we lost them boys
yeah and just just be very sincere when
you ask for guidance as to the creative
full guidance and um of course you know
when you're reading reflect on what
you're reading
and if you have questions like see
people of knowledge that can answer
these questions for you don't just seek
um brothers who may be Muslim and
they're like and even though like they
might have the answer and they might
have the best intention at heart like
you you generally want to go to people
of knowledge and Trust like if you don't
know anyone that's of knowledge just ask
your Muslim friends
where they are and they'll lead you to
them inshallah
sorry I guess uh stream yard froze for
about a minute
yeah no you you were saying though you
said that um this was uh this year you
you retired from being an Imam yes in
July
why why
it's a it's a long story because as I
said I was doing three full-time jobs at
the same time it was an Imam full time I
was a guy doing dawa full time and I was
also working on these books full time so
I put about
a minimum of 10 hours 10 to 12 hours
every single day even though I was doing
full-time job so I was babysitting my
kids I was
so subhanallah but Allah made it easy
and I was able to produce like
you know two three books at the same
time so I was working with a dictionary
I was working on the clear Chrome for
kids volume one I was working on a story
called shukran The Grateful young man at
the same time and and Allah
in the work and I have decided that you
know what
I think that the clear Quran requires
all of my effort and all of my time so I
gave it all up uh I gave up my dollar
job I gave up my Imam job so I can focus
100 on these books uh the click on for
kids the dictionary and there are so
many other products that projects that
are in the works and this this project
is actually Four volumes
for volumes a clear Quran for kids
so uh by the time we finish in uh by
Ramadan the book will be released
Ramadan 2024 it would have taken us
eight years
that's two years per volume
a team of over 100 people working on
each of these books uh writing editing
uh illustrations designing printing so
this is a huge project man
you know translating the Quran itself is
a is a tremendous project but when you
bring it down to the level of the kids
to to their understanding is also
another challenge
and working with a big team of kids
about 70 kids between the ages of 7 to
12. to translate the Quran for them to
make it easy understandable for them
this is a huge challenge so I had to
give it all of my time and all of my
efforts
did you did you stop babysitting your
kids as well
alhamdulillah it's much better now
because I I back then I sent my wife to
school she was a doctor in Egypt and she
was studying naturopathic medicine
so I had to drive the kids and cook for
them and babysit them and most of the
time alhamdulillah while doing so many
other projects but it's Allah who helps
alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah that's crazy
look at this comment someone wrote is
the brother of the clear Quran I cannot
tell you how much I can thank you for
this book The Transition is too good
that's from Allah not from me
we got one from uh Dr Hamza it says
please give my sincerest greetings in
regards to stud Mustafa let him know
I'll be soon reaching out to him may
Allah keep us all firm and steadfast
upon Islam I mean I mean
so what is the best place to reach you
at uh for other people aside from Dr
homes I don't want to get in touch with
you you can use my email Imam Mustafa K
gmail.com
okay oh no bro you got any questions
should I go yeah I was gonna ask by any
chance do you give any kind of courses
do you teach any kind of courses do you
have like a team who they teach certain
courses maybe it could be like Arabic or
just something having to do in this
field
well for for now because I'm so busy
with these clear Chrome projects if I
get an invitation like an online
conference or an event or a talk I do
that but for courses I have put a uh uh
stop on that for now until I finish so
maybe after a year
two years inshallah when I finish all
these projects I'm going to focus on
teaching the clip on dictionary
so maybe I'm in a portal
you study at your pace four months six
months a year
and you get a certificate you understand
the whole Quran and maybe I'm going to
teach a course on the clear quantities
here for kids
to make it easy for them inshallah
but one thing at a time yeah yeah
inshallah that's how we get things done
one thing at a time
but a lot of my talks and lectures are
available on YouTube the ones that I
recorded in the past you just go to
YouTube punch in my name one word my
channel will come up inshallah okay
inshallah and the difference between
someone going on to the Quran dictionary
and just kind of going at it themselves
versus them doing like this online
course that you would do later on what
would be the difference there
well I would say the the Cleveland has
been designed for self-study uh the
words you can read the you know the
transliteration of the words you can
read them on your own
and I made it very easy very clear so
you can study it on your own at your
pace but you have to start with the
introduction because it will help you to
figure out
the name the verb the particle and there
is also something very interesting about
the Arabic language you can actually
tell the meaning of a word
by the way it sounds so for example most
of the words that have thick letters
like
they have negative meaning but the words
that have thin uh letters like
most of the time they are positive words
so for example let me give you an
example uh
foreign even if you don't know the
Arabic language you know that the word
is a harsh word it means rocks in Arabic
you have the word Asal which means honey
you have the word
justice and you have the word Blazer
blizza
which means Injustice
uh and so on and so forth
so basically
uh you can start it on your own but I
think with the help of the newly
released app the click on Dictionary app
you can download it for free to sample
it uh you can use that as an aid until
inshallah I teach I teach my class I
know that some Islamic schools and
health
programs across North America they
started to use the click on dictionary
with their students so if the program is
four years by the time the students
finish the four years they know the two
thousand words
because memorizing by itself is good but
of course it's more important to
understand as well so memorizing is good
but it's better also to understand what
you're memorizing inshallah 100.
I got a question though
sure sure a lot of people in my family
in my community you know let's say
they're born Muslim but they haven't
been practicing most of their life you
know and they they have this you know
they're called to Islam later in their
life right so now they're kind of like
okay what is more beneficial to do
should I spend my time like and then
there's also you know more Baraka you
know finishing the Quran before Eid you
know in Ramadan we all know this so they
always ask this question you know I hear
this very often should I spend my time
reciting the Quran or should I spend my
time reading the translation and
understanding what it means
I would say the best thing to do is to
read the Quran in Arabic
but let's be practical more than 85
percent of Muslims they don't know or
speak the Arabic language Arabs are
actually a minority within the Muslim
Community only 15 or less
so basically the Quran is a universal
message so what are you going to do if
you don't speak the Arabic language so
you can read the translation you read
the understanding of some big Scholars
the Giants of tafsir they explain the
ayat for you but really the difference
between reading the Quran in Arabic and
reading the Quran in Translation is like
eating fresh and canned food it will
just give you a flavor but it is not the
same thing uh also
when it comes to your personal
relationship with the Quran there are
steps
spoke about
the most basic level is to read in
Arabic or in translation
the next level is to memorize if you can
the third level is to understand what
you are memorizing and what you are
reading
in Translation in tafsir the next level
is
in the Arabic language means back or
bottom so technically it means to get to
the bottom of something
to really understand deeply what it says
like the back of your hand remember we
said backward bottom you get to the
bottom of the Ayah you understand it
like the back of your hand and people
have been really doing to the board on
the Quran since the time of the Prophet
saws
every generation finds gems that the
previous generation didn't know and this
is something unique about the Quran you
reach experience
you read a book a novel once Angelas you
throw it you don't want to read it again
but the Quran people have been reading
it
they read the Quran hundreds or
thousands of times
and still the beauty the love the
sweetness is is there
also one thing you need to do you live
your life according to the Quran
uh you know um
they say that he completed his health of
Surah baqarah just one Surah in 12 years
it took him 12 years why because he said
he wouldn't move to the next five ayat
until he practiced the first five
so he understood his connection with the
Quran is not just something that you
listen to when someone dies in a janaza
you just listen to the recitation
um some people subhanallah they just I
don't know about you but in Egypt car
insurance is not fund it's not like a
must you have to have car insurance and
a lot of people just keep a copy of the
Quran in the trunk or in the dashboard
just for protection you know uh some
people subhanallah I did this when I was
young I didn't know about this tahara
you know praying to Allah for guidance
when you make a decision so we used to
open like in a random page and the first
Ayah that you see this is what you're
going to follow so if it talks about
enjoyment if it talks about Jannah oh
this is a good sign I'm gonna do it if
it talks about roasting in jahannam and
suffering oh I'm gonna run away you know
but this is not the reason why Allah
Quran
so we should read it understand it live
our lives according to it apply it to
our lives and teach it to others and do
the double in it and the Quran says that
he Allah has revealed the Quran as a
shifa a healing for everything
for the individual for the family for
the society for the Muslim ummah
all the issues all the problems that we
have in our lives their Solutions are in
the Quran and Allah has sampled the
prophets in the Quran not all the
prophets who have been sent from the
time of Adam to Muhammad are mentioned
by name in the Quran this is what Allah
says
we told you this the stories the names
of some of the prophets but some others
we have not told you their names or
their stories Allah sampled them so in
our life we have we have the economy
social life we have politics we have
family so if you want to learn about
politics read the story of Musa with
fraud
if you want to learn about
social life family Dynamics read the
story views of Allah if you want to
learn about financial corruption you
read the story of schweib and his people
and of course the prophet saws his life
covers all of these aspects so Allah
says that the Quran is a healing for
sure
now I'm going to tell you a story to
illustrate I love stories
I know a friend he's an Imam in the UK
he said this is a true story that
happened a long time ago back in uh in
the day in Egypt the Imam said his
relative
had an ear infection and he went to the
doctor so the doctor examined his ear
and he said oh you have an ear infection
you have to take these tablets take a
tablet every eight hours and I want to I
want to see you in three days
so the patient didn't wait for three
days uh first in the morning next day he
came back to the doctor and he was in
pain he's a doctor I took the first
tablet I was in pain I took the second
one I was crying I took the third one I
couldn't sleep the whole night
so the doctor said okay let me
re-examine your ear and the doctor
looked inside his ear and sure enough he
found the three tablets stuffed inside
his ear
this is true story so the medicine was
correct but the way the patient was
using the medicine was wrong and I think
this is what many of us do when it comes
to the Quran Allah says it's a healing
but we don't use it the way it should be
used the way I explained reading it
understanding it applying it to our
lives seeking shifa through the Quran
this should sum up your relationship
with the Quran really
um
my next question is going to be in me
and anho we've been dealing with a lot
of you know brothers and friends that
we've had you know kind of before Islam
they're kind of still non-muslim and
sometimes we try to give them dawah and
Mela guide them all honestly and without
giving details there was there were some
brothers that we were talking about you
know they would come to us they would
ask us about you know the Quran you know
I'm reading this and at that time ano
has already become Muslim so we would
try to you know tell them this is why
this this is why that one thing I heard
on Jose a lot was you need to go into it
with an empty mind like with no
preconceived notions with no you know
Fox News type of thing no narrative just
go into it just blank right and they
would try to do that sorry was that
empty cup empty cup they will try to do
that but then when they would come
they'd be like okay uh but what about
this one you know David wood says in
chapter nine this happens you know or
what about this person I see online
Jordan Peterson or this other person you
know they're talking about the violent
verses in chapter 15. I'm like bro how
are you already in chapter 15. you just
you know what I mean how are you in the
15 Surah so what advice would you have
for a lot of these brothers and sisters
that are interested in the Quran but
they they might be having some type of
bias when they read it you know one
thing I personally would tell them is
just to Envision that this is literally
Allah God the one Creator speaking to
you just this is this is his message but
what advice would you have it's it's a
very good question uh number one the
brother who is asking the question this
is my message to you you are not better
than the prophet saws and the person you
are doing dollar to is not better than
Abu Talib
so the prophet saws was doing dawah to
his uncle for years
uh he gave him all the reasoning all the
proofs he recited the Quran he saw the
character of the Prophet saws
but it didn't work out for him because
he died at the end of the day is not in
my hand is not in your hands it's in the
hand of Allah
and
this is part of the uh of the murajiza
of Allah this part of his his his power
and his might
you read the series you see someone like
um
the sahaba used to say that Roma will
not accept Islam until his father's
donkey takes shahada
which means impossible
and when you read the story of Abu Talib
the uncle of the Prophet saws how he
defended him how he took care of him how
nice he was to him he so next page he
was going to become Muslim
and what happens
never accepted Islam
accepted Islam right after and he became
a giant of Islam so basically he dies in
the hands of Allah this is something
that we need to understand
the people who come to us or the people
that we speak to talk to about Islam
they need to understand something
um I wish they treat the Quran the same
way they treat their own Bibles or they
achieve their own books uh because let's
say for example violence
the word
is mentioned in the Quran maybe 20 25 30
times Max whereas our references to
violence or killing in the Bible more
than five thousand times
right
five thousand times so people they
they're not fair in the way they treat
these books
and when they read
the Quran they actually come it with
preconceived notions and they look for
you know some ammunition excuses that
justify their disbelief I'll just give
you an example
for example I'm a farmer by birth I like
farming I like nature so when I was
young I learned something very
interesting from a very young age in the
village in Egypt by the nari river which
is behind our
backyard we have a stream from the Nile
River I used to see the bees and the
Flies
flying in the farm you know they fly the
bees and the Flies and they see
everything from the top
but eventually
bees always landed on flowers and flies
always landed on garbage
people are the same way some people come
to the Quran with the bi
mashallah they are positive they read
with an open heart and an open mind they
would benefit
but those who come
they just come to confirm they the junk
they heard from David wood and other
islamophobes so these people have the
fly eye they come they just look for the
junk they read from other people they
have not actually read the Quran they
read about the Quran what a hater what
an islamophobes said about the Quran and
this is not fair you know all you need
to do just come to the Quran with an
open heart an open mind and read for
yourself
see if it makes sense or not and take
the challenge of the Quran Allah says if
you think this book is not from me make
something like it if you think this book
is not from me find a mistake in it it
is that simple
and I've seen so many people subhanallah
the majority of the people
that who came to Islam
they accepted Islam because they read
the Quran they came across an Ayah that
touched their hearts I know some people
come to Islam because they met a good
Muslim and so on and so forth but a
sizable number of the viewer except
Islam was because of something they read
in the Quran that really touched him
well something they read about the
prophet saws
so
when people read the Quran
they're not actually reading it the
Quran is reading them
so if they come looking for excuses not
to believe Allah will give it to them
those who are coming sincerely to look
for guidance Allah will give it to them
right so Allah
says in the Quran that is
he guides whoever he wills and he
misguides or leads astray whoever he
wills and some of the scholars say that
whoever Wills could be the pronoun could
refer to Allah or could refer to the
person himself Allah guides those who
want to be guided and he leaves astray
those who don't want to be guided so
whatever you want Allah will give it to
you
right
so I think this is something to think
about inshallah this is so this is so
interesting subhanallah because a lot of
people they say oh you know what it's
it's it's not my fault if Allah just
chose not to guide me you know what I
mean or it's not up to me I you know I
didn't choose to be misguided Allah got
two evils but it does come down to the
individual person you're right
yes of course Allah
he tells the prophet saws in one place
you guide in another place guidance is
not in your hands because there are two
types of guidance
like you show someone away
this is one type and this is the job of
the Prophet saws
but for them to actually take that path
and walk the path
this is their own job and this is in the
hands of Allah
so our job is just show the way explain
give proofs
alhamdulillah and hidayah at the end of
the day is in the hands of Allah
but if the if Islam is explained clearly
to someone
and they reject it
then they will have no excuse
they have to answer for their denial if
it explains for them clearly
hmm
I think that's a wonderful point to end
it on
um me and on her at least me I got Juma
soon because I'm in Eastern Standard
Time uh Arnold's late firm in France
um but
ustad is there anything else that you
wanted to leave for the viewers before
we wrap this up and next time when we
get around me inshallah we can continue
this
inshallah my advice to everyone
is have a personal connection with the
Quran
the big ulama of
islamia the different Scholars they used
to say subhanallah they spent most of
their life reading the Quran but they
were also working on
Hadith and before they died many of them
said I regret not spending my whole life
entirely 100 to the service of the Quran
so dedicate your time to reading the
Quran to understanding the life the zero
the prophet saws and this is the way to
go inshallah we hope that Allah will
bless all of us guide us and we we ask a
lot to use us for the guidance of others
inshallah
so uh brother Sammy writes I 100 feel
the pull to Allah in Islam I can't deny
it hey guys I just want to introduce
myself t3m has been very helpful as I
learn and grow I'm currently reading an
older translation of the Quran but I'm
waiting on a new copy inshallah you got
the clear Quran
um another uh sister wrote my kids
benefited so much from the kids version
even as a Medina book student I found
that English is not enough to truly
understand the Quran
there are so many grammatical gems that
English loses out yes
thank you so much for your time
yes
[Music]
and with that being said see you guys
next time
thank you